we are joined Now by CBS News legal
analyst Ricky cleeman and CBS News Chief
election and campaign correspondent
Robert Costa good morning to you both
Ricky let's start with you how strong is
this case now that we see the actual
case done with the speculation how
strong is the case
not at the indictment itself which is
boilerplate but when you look at the
statement of facts the statement effects
go into great detail the question is
which crime do the falsified business
records connect to is it a tax crime is
it a federal election violation or is it
a state election violation or is it
three of the above and I think it would
be better for everyone if we knew
exactly what statute if you look at the
Federal indictment of Michael Cohen and
you look at each charge it tells you it
gives you the number of the charge so
you can go look it up so that's what's
missing here doesn't mean it's not
strong I would just like to know which
statute and the reason you'd like to
know which statute is it's that statute
that elevates it from a misdemeanor to a
felony is that precisely got it would
you rather be defending or uh
Prosecuting this case well I always
thought that being a public prosecutor
tutor which I was for a number of years
was the greatest job I have ever had
because you could do justice because you
had discretion in what cases you brought
in what cases you didn't bring and in
sentencing recommendations but as a
scrapper I think that that part of me
would love to go forward and do the
Motions in this case for the defense but
that's very divorced from the person
that I am that's the lawyer that I am
Bob let's talk about where this goes
because former president Trump is also a
presidential candidate the next hearing
is December 4th which we get into that
tricky timeline of you know he's a
defendant in this case but he also is
running a campaign at what point does he
have to take his eye off the ball if he
will ever off the legal case and look
ahead to what voters want to hear about
the issues that they care about or does
this Define his campaign it's such an
important question and speaking of being
a scrapper so many of former president
Trump's rivals in the Republican Party
believe if he is a scrapper politically
and though they may want to win the
nomination themselves many of them
remain reluctant to get into the arena
with someone who is now so combative
both legally and politically Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis has not yet
announced those who have been recruited
like Virginia Governors Glenn Younkin
have resisted getting into the race
there's a belief now that Trump has
Consolidated a lot of his support in the
Republican party but they do not believe
inside his own Inner Circle that he's
going to change his tune anytime in the
coming months that it's instead it's
going to be his grievances his anger
that really fuel him toward that
Republican nomination versus any
particular policy position you use the
word combative and that can describe his
tone last night in his speech is there
any legal risk Ricky I'll ask you of him
talking as he leads up to maybe a
campaign run well I'm sure as his lawyer
I would like him to be quiet and I would
think that at least some of his lawyers
would like him to just up especially
with threatening remarks it can never
really serve you but what the lawyer has
to think about is that any statement you
make extrajudicial statement any
statement out of court that you make or
you write or you post could be
introduced in evidence in a court of law
if it looks like an admission so would I
like him to just stop of course as a
lawyer but he is a political candidate
which throws it right back to Boston
that's not a style and not his style
it's also not his goal yeah and when you
think too that he's already fundraising
off of this we saw that fake mug shot
with the t-shirts Bob you know he's
using this as his political fire you
know how much more can we expect that
that is the campaign a lot on what's
happening in New York they're going to
use that New York case as a political
Target but when you talk to Trump's
confidants and his closest advisors they
are on edge about what's happening as
Scott detailed in the other
investigation especially in the Federal
grand jury investigations being led by
the special counsel he is being
investigated right now for whether he
obstructed the return of those
classified records to the federal
government that's the point of alarm
among some Trump Associates at this
moment before we move on let me say
thank you for working around the clock
great coverage yesterday waking up early
with us you get up early every morning
no but you guys did agree you carried it
all afternoon at night thank you Ricky
and Bob thank you so much